Achterbahnfahren ist für diese
Französinnen uncool.
Die haben den meisten
Spaß mit ihrem Handy.
Aber mit einer Virtual-Reality-Brille
könnte es doch wieder aufregend sein.
Ich sehe schneebedeckte Bäume
und Leute vor mir.
Aber ich sehe euch Mädels
hier nicht mehr.
Die Achterbahn „Pegasus“ im
Europapark in Rust.
Maximal 13 Meter hoch,
nicht schneller als 60 Kilometer pro Stunde
– eine Familienbahn.
Und wer will, fährt mit einer Datenbrille
durch völlig neue Welten:
alles schneller, alles spektakulärer.
Michael Mack, der Chef des Europaparks:
Er hat mehr als eine Million Euro investiert,
um zwei seiner Bahnen mit
dieser Technik auszustatten.
Sein Gast heute – ein Vertreter
eines Freizeitparks in Brasilien.
Er probiert es hautnah aus. Und er soll
das Geschäft dahinter verstehen:
Statt Millionen-Investitionen in neue Bahnen
können alte einfach aufgepeppt werden.
Ein zusätzlicher Kick im Kopf.
Das war eigentlich so das [der] größte
Wow-Effekt, und der funktioniert.
Also, viele Gäste kommen
aus der Bahn raus und sagen:
Herr Mack, Sie haben mir doch gesagt,
es ist ohne Überschlag, die Achterbahn.
Sie haben mich veräppelt, oder Sie haben
mich angelogen, da war ein Überschlag drin.
bis sie mir dann wirklich geglaubt haben,
dass da kein Überschlag in der Bahn ist.
Die Virtual-Reality-Brillen
haben ein Smartphone eingebaut.
Das ist per Bluetooth mit einem
Schaltkasten unter dem Sitz verbunden.
So läuft der Film im Smartphone
absolut synchron zur Position der Bahn.
Der Berater glaubt schon jetzt: In ganz
Südamerika wird sich das gut verkaufen.
Die virtuelle Realität wird
gerade ganz groß dort.
Es gibt ja auch schon die augmented reality,
wie dieses kleine Pokémon-Spiel,
was gerade so populär ist. Jeder wird
reingezogen in diese Technologie.
Wenn es so sein kann wie hier,
werden sie es lieben.
Hinter dem Freizeitpark steckt das
Familienunternehmen Mack
– ein Hersteller für Achterbahn-Hardware,
also Schienen und Gondeln.
Doch jetzt das Geschäft
mit der Virtualität: Achterbahn 4.0.
Smartphone und Brille – zusammen für
etwa 800 Euro gekauft, 300 Stück.
Den Schaltkasten hat der
Technikchef selbst entwickelt.
Die 3D-Filme stammen von einem
Spin-off der Uni Kaiserslautern.
Das Schwierigste: Filmsequenzen und reale,
manchmal unebene Bahnen
zu synchronisieren.
Und die Schläge haben
wir dann auch genutzt.
Zum Beispiel hier haben wir
dann den Sprung über diese Klippen.
Und dann genau da, wo wir aufsetzen, und
das haben wir dann genau synchronisiert …
Und schon hat er neue Visionen:
Der Gast könnte doch auch
in der virtuellen Realität handeln.
Man kann irgendwie durch ’n Knopfdruck
auf Gegenstände schießen
und am Ende ein Punktesystem
haben und sehen: Okay,
ich hab‘ jetzt 100.000 Punkte gesammelt.
Oder noch weitergehen:
Irgendwann wird… wird’s dann
vielleicht auch möglich sein,
dass man dann auch die Hände sieht
und dann mit den Händen noch in
der VR-Welt irgendwas macht,
Objekte berühren kann und
die sammeln kann oder greifen kann.
Einen Großteil seines Umsatzes macht der
Chef mit dem Verkauf seiner Achterbahnen.
95 Prozent exportiert er.
Künftig auch die
Virtual-Reality-Technologie und die Filme
– für 4000 vorhandene
Achterbahnen weltweit.
Der Markt ist nach wie vor in Amerika,
China ist ‘n starker Markt,
Asien im Allgemeinen.
Indien wird in den nächsten ein,
zwei Jahren kommen,
also stark asiatische Märkte und
amerikanische Märkte.
Irgendwann, so Mack, könnten die Besucher
vielleicht unter tausenden Filmen wählen.
Je nach Geschmack: Science-Fiction-Flüge,
Horrortrips oder vielleicht Märchenwelten.